one of the things that i'm working on
that others should work on i think is
around lowering the barrier
uh to entry for
people from different academic
backgrounds to interrogate systems
so we have a lot of people developing
technology
and that's great but we don't have a lot
of people who are
in a situation where they can really
question the technology because there's
often a bottleneck where for example if
you want to know about data
directly you have to be able to like log
into a server server and like right
sql query
so it's like there where the rubber
meets the road there's a bottleneck
where engineers have to do it and i want
to remove that bottleneck yeah so that's
a lot of the work i'm doing at hugging
face now like how can we take things
that are fundamentally
technical code stuff and open it up so
that thing is done under the hood and
people can directly query without
needing to know how to program yeah and
i think that's just in general we are
going to be able to make better
technology
when we remove the barriers that require
engineers to be
in the middle
absolutely what the work should be